[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Hi, everyone.
Welcome to "Talks at Google."
Thanks so much for
joining us today.
It's my pleasure to
welcome Sarah Robb
O'Hagan to the office to
talk about her new book,
"Extreme You--
Step up, Stand Out,
Kick Ass, Repeat."
The book not only inspires
you to take risks and step out
of the box, but is also
funny, entertaining,
and super-interesting
as she takes you
through her own personal
journey of success and failure,
and how they have got her
to where she is today.
Please join me in welcoming her.
[APPLAUSE]
SARAH ROBB O'HAGAN: Thank you.
Good morning, Googlers.
How is everyone?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
SARAH ROBB O'HAGAN:
Ready to rock it out?
All right.
So I generally like to stop my
talks with just a little bit
of context.
Where's the crazy accent from?
I am from New Zealand.
Has anyone been
there in the room?
Ah, yes.
There's always one.
There's two!
Is it amazing?
It's kind of amazing.
It was discovered
in 1769, actually,
by Captain James Cook,
who wrote in his log book,
I believe I have found God zone.
I mean, I'm not even kidding.
It's the most gorgeous
place on the planet.
So why would I leave
New Zealand, you wonder?
Well, there's like
4 million people
and almost 50 million sheep.
Let's just start there.
That is not like a joke.
That is exactly what
my country looks like.
So as a young person
growing up, you
can imagine I had a lot
of like, well, is this it?
Is this my people, or is
there more in the world?
How do we go beyond?
New Zealand is also
a country that is
very passionate about sports.
I love that I've got my crew
team in the back row here
today.
So like Americans-- we're
really into sport in America.
Well, in New Zealand,
we're a little country,
but we like swing hard.
In the 1984 Olympics,
which most of you
probably can't even remember
because you weren't born,
I was like a 12-year-old
watching on TV
as we got the most medals
we've ever won in our history.
And that was 12 medals.
You guys, it's amazing.
We were number 1 on the global
per capita medals table.
That's a big deal to us.
But what's really cool about
it is every medal that we won
involved a sport where
they were sitting down.
Isn't that amazing?
Look at the pictures.
Like, literally.
Cycling, rowing,
kayaking, horse riding.
I could go on,
like we crushed it
at the sports that involved--
who would have thought, right?
So why am I sharing
this funny story
with you, is
because I do believe
as a young person growing
up, it did leave quite
a profound thought with me.
And that is that it
takes extreme focus
to achieve
extraordinary results.
Like those little kiwis
punching above their weight,
you have to really
have focus on something
that is your unique specialty.
And you'll see in
the pictures here,
I've had the great pleasure of
working for some of the world's
most incredible brands.
Sustaining, amazing brands.
And what they all have in
common is this detailed focus
on what they are, where they're
going, why they're unique.
And they don't get distracted
as the years go by.
And that's especially
important when the landscape
is so rapidly changing.
And for me being someone who's
gone everything from Virgin
Megastores-- does anyone even
remember Virgin Megastores--
when the music
industry got disrupted
and that company no
longer exists through
to the likes of Nike, which is
driving innovation and pushing
forward more than any
other company in the world.
The big difference is
those that consistently
play their own game,
but just stay in front
and disrupt themselves before
the industry does it to them.
So I've had these great
career experiences.
And the process
of writing my book
led me to say, well,
what does this actually
mean for individuals
as well and leaders?
And you can see here, over the
last three years, it's been,
I have interviewed 25 of some of
the most profoundly successful
people on the planet.
Because I wanted to know,
just like those brands,
what is it about them that
uniquely enables them to stay
on the top of their game?
And what I did is I
went to great lengths
to sort of go to
all walks of life.
So you see some of
the pictures here,
everyone from Condoleezza
Rice, who we all know,
who is like the world's
most amazing bad-ass,
through to Bode Miller,
who's a downhill skier,
through to Mister Cartoon,
who's one of the world's
most famous tattoo artists.
Sam Kass, the White House chef.
What they all have in common
is this incredible ability
to know their own specialties,
to know what they're
amazing at, to focus,
like those little kiwis,
and to constantly
disrupt themselves.
Whenever they get to
mastery, push themselves
to the next level.
So with that said, I
think about this framework
that I've been developing
and discovering.
And it starts with
you, the person,
like those individuals
I just talked about.
What is extreme you?
What is you at your
most optimum potential?
What is the core set of
skills that you have?
And generally, extremers,
as I call them,
are not well-rounded.
They're not the
kinds of people that
have tons of experience
in a lot of places.
They're probably super-good
at one specialty,
and really passionate
about it, and we love them
in the workplace.
However, they need
to be partnered
with complementary people
to become extreme teams,
like when we get lots of
complementary skills together.
And then ultimately,
the extreme organization
is that organization
that is loaded
with people with incredible
skills in specialist areas.
But together, they come together
and focus on a really, really
focused mission.
So with that said, I'm going to
go through three examples today
of the kind of key
tenants that I learned
from all these amazing
businesses and all
these amazing leaders in
developing the idea that
was "Extreme You."
And the first one is what I like
to call make failure your fuel.
It is possibly my most
favorite topic in the world.
And it starts with
the fact that I
have had a career, mainly in
the sports and fitness industry.
If you Googled me
a couple of years
ago, what you would
have seen is that I
was known for turning around
Gatorade, a $5 billion sports
drink business.
I had all these things
like, "Fast Company's" Most
Creative People in Business.
That looks amazing, right?
But what it totally left out
was the fact that in my 20s,
I got fired not once,
but twice back to back.
And I like to share
the story because I
believe in our culture
today of success.
Whether it's lists of the
40 under 40, 30 under 30,
20 under 20.
Whether it's perfectly
coiffed Instagram pictures,
we tend to show all
the amazing stuff
and we don't tend to show some
of the really embarrassing,
not so cool stuff.
So one of the reasons
I wrote this book was I
felt it was important to share,
particularly with young people,
that you have to fail in
order to know who you are
and in order to
succeed in the future.
My example of Virgin,
like I mentioned,
was Virgin Megastores.
I joined in the late '90s, the
year Napster had come along.
So let's just go there.
Remember that.
I still remember
like our big moment.
It was May and we had to
comp Ricky Martin's album
sales from the year before.
Like, that's how awesome it was.
But in the end, the
company actually
went under for all the
reasons I said before,
because they were being
disrupted from outside
and not taking
care of themselves.
But my experience
was someone who'd
come in from a high-flying role
at Virgin Atlantic Airways.
I thought I had it down.
I was like, rocking
and rolling, not
listening to anyone around me
in a totally foreign business.
So over my skis, so arrogant.
And I got fired.
Not like laid off,
one-person fired.
And let me explain
to you what that
feels like when you go into the
office and HR is sitting there.
And you feel the blood
rush out of your face
and you get told that you
have a one-week severance.
They're getting rid
of your green card
application and your visa.
And you get a one-way
ticket back to New Zealand.
In other words, we don't
want you in our company.
We don't even want
you in our country.
Like, that's how awesome it was.
So I go through that,
and then desperate times
call for desperate measures.
I have three months to
stay in the country.
And I end up taking
a job at Atari.
Does anyone in this
room remember Atari?
Some fond fans, I would imagine.
Which was a disaster for me
because I completely overlooked
the fact that I cannot
stand video games.
Never have liked him.
Have no interest in them.
Don't understand them.
Within two years, that's
another company in distress
and a bunch of people
are getting laid off.
And of course, I'm one of them.
So by this stage, I'm
now in my late 20s.
I've had up to four years
of epic career failure.
Disastrous.
I call it fondly my
"canyon of career despair."
It was terrible.
But here's the thing.
That same person that
was a total flame-out
in these two environments.
Eventually, after
I leave Atari, I'm
desperately trying to
find the right role
for me going forward.
I finally land at
Nike after 12 months
of interviewing and trying
and getting in the door.
And that same
loser girl suddenly
becomes on the fast track,
having a great career,
and rocking and rolling.
And the lesson
here for me was you
have to experience extreme
environments to understand
where you suck and
where you thrive.
And when you get yourself
onto the playing field
where you thrive,
it feels amazing.
And you know the difference.
And all your
confidence comes back.
And that is the importance of
failure on the way to success.
Because quite
honestly, had I not
just gone through those
two back-to-back firings,
I don't think I would have had
the humility coming in the door
to succeed at Nike.
I mean, literally
I walk in the door
and I'm like, please,
don't fire me.
Please, don't fire me.
I will do anything
to do well here.
And one of the great
athletes that I
had the pleasure of working
with when I was at Nike
was Bode Miller.
Do you guys know Bode?
He's awesome, by the way.
I mean, the best
skier in the world
to watch because
there is nothing
between disqualified and gold.
That's just the way he rolls.
But I really got to know
him around the 2006 Torino
Olympics.
And he's extraordinary when
you talk to him about failure.
Because he talked
about as a child, when
he was learning to
ski in New Hampshire,
he physically was smaller
than the other skiers,
so he kept coming
in like 30th, 40th.
Like, certainly not
podium potential, right?
And the trainers kept
saying to all of them,
well, you've just got to kind
of push yourself incrementally.
That was the way they were
training skiers in those days.
And he's like, well, that
ain't working for me, clearly.
So finally, he's like,
I got to go my own way
and figure this out.
And he starts
skiing in practice,
like balls to the wall.
If anyone's watched this guy
ski, there is no holding back.
And he would crash a lot.
And it was painful.
But as he said,
that was pushing him
to the edge of his own
boundaries, edge of his comfort
level, and teaching him to
be able to eventually recover
in those crashes to
get to the next level.
So on race day, when the other
guys suddenly go full steam
ahead, they're crashing.
He actually now can
push to a higher level
because he's taught himself
through the very act
of crashing and failing and
pain to get to the next level.
So a great metaphor
for all of us as we
think about our own careers.
All right.
So that's making
failure your fuel.
Number 2, I like
to talk about is
playing your specialist game.
What does that mean
for you personally?
So I came upon this idea from
studying these great brands
and businesses that
I've been lucky enough
to be involved with.
And I would pick out a few
here just to share with you.
So Virgin Atlantic Airways.
Has anyone flown Virgin?
Is it not awesome?
You get your hair
done at the clubhouse.
It's amazing.
But Virgin's super-interesting
to me because having spent
about eight years in
the airline industry,
most of you would know if
you fly United or American--
especially this week.
But their target audience
is generally human beings
with arms and legs.
You know what I'm saying?
Whereas, Virgin, when they
came into the business,
they're like, we're not
going after everyone.
We're going to have this
really defined position.
And we're going
to focus on people
who are into culture, and
technology, and entertainment,
and fashion.
Everything was built
around that positioning.
And as a result, they've
built this incredible position
as an airline.
They think of the
travel experience,
I think, more as
entertainment than travel.
I mean, they even
got to the point
where they were
able to sort of be
an arbiter of great
taste of movies in flight
because they thought
about it that way.
Likewise, Strava.
Do I have any Strava
users in the room?
I cannot believe that.
We've got to get you
out on your bikes, guys.
Strava is the social
network for athletes.
They're based out
in Silicon Valley.
And what they do is, obviously,
track runners, cycling,
all these sort of
fitness activities.
But as the founder said to
me when I interviewed them
for my book, like at
the time they were born,
the Fitbit market
was what everyone
was going after because
it's big and it's massive.
And they like, well, we could
have done that, but then we
would have been number 10 in
a giant market instead of they
just went after cyclists
and only cyclists.
And they were number 1 for
this really small group.
And from there, they've
managed to push out
because they're going after
very, very passionate athletes.
And then lastly, the Drybar.
Ladies in this room nodding.
The guys right now
are going, WTF?
What is Drybar?
They are.
I can tell.
Drybar is an
extraordinary story.
I love it.
I interviewed Alli, the
founder, for my book.
Basically, for many
years, hairdressing was--
certainly, on the
women's side, you
go to a hairdresser
and anything you
want to get done, you get done.
So cuts, colors, get your hair
blown out, any of the above.
Well Alli, who
founded the Drybar,
was like, I really don't
want to do all of that stuff.
I'm just really good
at blowing out hair
because I've loved doing
it since I was a child.
And I want to create
an entire concept just
around that one thing.
Now, most people would
say, how the hell
are you going to build a
business around that one thing
when women need all these
other things done from a beauty
standpoint as well?
But she's like, I'm going to
be better than anyone at doing
this one thing.
Sure enough, Drybar is now
coming close to 100 million
top-line business
based on the fact
that she's created an entire
category out of this one thing.
Because women, we didn't
used to rock along and spend
$65 for a blow out
once or twice a week.
Because the category didn't
exist, she's now created it.
And there's many, obviously,
people following her.
And she gets so many
people saying, well,
why don't you add makeup, or
nails, or all the other things
that women would want?
She's like, because that would
take away my focus from what
I'm really, really good at.
And I want to be the
best at this one thing.
And it's such a great
lesson because when
you take all of
those brand lessons,
and then think about
yourself as an individual.
How do you think about
yourself being positioned
like a brand would be?
How do you think
about your career
in terms of imagining
that you are
that product in the
marketplace that you're trying
to attract people to come by?
Do you feel just like
those three examples
that you are super-uniquely
differentiated?
Do you feel like
the airline example
that you're just trying to
be all things to all people?
Or do you have your
one unique thing?
Do you feel like
Alli, that you have
that specialty that you really
are better at than anyone else?
Because I do believe
when you have that,
and you become super
world-class, that
propels your career forward.
So in my example, I actually
spent most of my life
being really, really,
really average.
So I'm talking
really wanted to be
a world-class Olympic
medal-winning athlete.
Never made the
A-team in any sport
that I participated in at all.
Really wanted to be a
world-famous singer or actress.
Never got picked for solos.
Actually, when we did
"Grease" at my high school,
I didn't even make
the pink ladies.
I was that section that
doesn't go on the stage.
Clearly, just not cut
out to be really amazing
in any of those things.
However, who would
have thought--
I didn't know--
15, 20 years later,
when I finally
had gone through all these
trials and tribulations, that
what I actually was developing
was this incredibly competitive
mindset.
I'm probably the most
competitive human
being in the room right now.
Combined with a
very creative brain
developed through tons
and tons of music.
Combined with years of
adventuring in the travel
industry, which
all comes together
to make me uniquely good
at innovation in the sports
and fitness industry.
Who would have thought?
I didn't even know
that was a career.
But when I pulled
those things together,
that's where I
suddenly found, wait,
I'm not getting fired anymore.
I've pulled it all together.
And it's interesting
for all of you
to understand, what
is that for you?
Because when you find
it, when you know it,
when opportunity
knocks-- boy, you
have to knock down the door.
And in my case, I, actually,
about six months ago,
was not working, not
looking for a job
because I was working on
the launch of this book.
And along comes an opportunity
with Flywheel Sports.
And I don't know if you
guys are familiar with it.
I'll quickly tell you a
little bit about Flywheel.
But it's unique
because it's not just
playing in the sports
and fitness industry.
It's actually way
into the specialty
that I happen to be uniquely
good at and passionate about.
So if you think about the
fitness industry right now--
and this may be going on in many
industries around the world--
we are moving fast from
one-size-fits-all to specialist
categories.
This is really interesting.
Back in the '90s, if
you think about retail,
we used to go to the
department store,
and then we started
going to boutique retail.
The same thing is
happening in fitness.
So you see all these little
boutiques popping up.
I'm sure some of you in the
room are attending them.
Whether it's cycling, little
running boutiques, boot camp,
like Barry's Bootcamp, if
anyone's attended that.
Zumba from a dance
standpoint, yoga,
all these little boutiques.
Now, those feel very specialist.
But interestingly, even
within the cycling category,
you would think that in
itself is a specialty.
But actually, there's three
different kinds of approach
to cycling as a category.
So if you look at
the kinds of people
that are attracted into
the boutique cycling world,
you have some for whom it's
a really social experience.
The number 1 reason
they're coming
is to be social and hang
out with their friends.
You have others, like my friend
in the middle of the room here,
who attends Flywheel,
who probably were
playing sports in high school.
They're probably a
little bit competitive.
Would I guess at that
just a little bit?
And they come for
performance because they're
trying to push their athletic
performance to the next level.
And then lastly, we
have people for whom
routine is what gets them in
the door to a fitness offering.
Because they don't love it.
It's not their lifestyle, but
they know they have to do it.
So they're just
looking for, what
is the thing that is most
convenient to where I live?
Three different people with
three completely different
motivations around which to
build a cycling business.
So the notion here is to be
spectacular for a few instead
of being average for many.
I love this chart.
You will all be able to find
yourselves on this chart.
This is the US population
and everybody's attitudes
to physical activity
and fitness.
So I will walk you through it.
To your right is 30% of the
population is simply inactive.
Totally don't work out at all.
They exist.
They're hard for me to
understand, but they exist.
Then, we have 18%,
which are what
we call chore exercisers,
for whom they really
don't like fitness.
The doctor told them to do it.
It's not fun at all, but they
do get out and push themselves.
Then, you have had workers,
physical laborers, obviously.
And then we get into
the more active.
So the social group
I mentioned before,
for whom it's a really
social activity that they
want to get out there.
And then, the routines,
as I mentioned.
And then, these last two
groups, passionate exercisers
and competitive athletes.
Now, competitive athletes.
15% of this population
intellectually type
as a competitive athlete.
That means you cannot let
your kids win at monopoly.
That means wherever you are,
if you're on a treadmill
next to someone, you are
aware of their numbers,
and you are trying to go faster.
You cannot help yourself.
That is what a
competitive athlete is.
And Flywheel has completely
attracted that one,
tiny segment because everything
about our offering-- we
have technology so you can
track your performance,
compete with others in the
room, compete with yourself.
And that is where we
focus all our energy.
We don't try and
go after all of it.
We go after just one.
And I do believe as a business,
that makes us stronger.
And certainly, as a leader.
I'm like, I'm with my people.
So I feel very comfortable
intuitively with the decisions
that I'm trying to make.
OK.
That was your specialist game.
So now lastly, I'm going to talk
about breaking yourself to make
herself, which is an important
lesson that I learned,
particularly from the extremers
I interviewed, that you
can never get complacent.
So firstly, that means
breaking yourself as a leader.
And I do believe, having gone
through the experience of being
fired a couple times, it really
sucks when it's done to you.
It's a whole lot better
to do it to yourself.
And that means
really recognizing,
when are you in
your comfort zone?
When have you been doing
the same thing for a while?
You've achieved mastery.
You feel amazing.
When is that time to
push to a different place
and get uncomfortable?
Now in my case, I actually
quit my job a year ago
to do just that.
I knew I wasn't
personally growing.
It was the scariest thing
I've ever done in my life.
But my god, it's like I'd
rather that than I didn't do it.
A few years went by, and I
suddenly wasn't keeping up.
And I got laid off again, right?
So what does that mean for you?
Where is that moment in
your career where you
have to really push outside?
And it involves challenging
your most stubborn beliefs.
I really have found, from a
lot of the research I've done,
that we do tend to in our
minds get these kind of beliefs
early on in our
career that we're not
good at certain things.
That we are either an analytical
person or a creative person,
or whatever the
category might be.
Often, those become
our blind spots
and we just don't kind of
want to deal with them.
But actually, you
should deal with them.
And it's OK.
That's breaking yourself
down to make yourself.
Like, what is it that you are
sort of avoiding in your job?
It isn't an area of
decision-making strength
for you.
Can you go and take an
out-of-work class on it
to really push yourself
to the next level?
Because that is
the kind of thing,
it will feel uncomfortable,
but it will certainly
get you there.
And then, break
yourself as a business.
So you've got to
think as a leader,
it is your responsibility
to constantly get
outside your comfort zone
and learn new things.
But you also have to think
as a business, what does
that mean organizationally?
I had the great experience
of working at Nike,
and then leaving at around the
time when the whole company was
re-orientating itself in terms
of how they worked together.
Going from footwear, apparel,
and equipment to categories--
soccer, running, et cetera.
And what that caused
was all of the employees
to move into a different place
of how they were interacting
with different
people to innovate,
which was actually
incredibly uncomfortable.
But obviously, leads to new
thinking and new innovation.
So what does that
mean for your teams?
Can you get them into
different train tracks
in order to create
new innovation?
And inspiration.
It's so important, I believe,
to look outside your category
to get inspiration for what
you may do going forward.
If I think about Strava,
like if we were just
to stay in category, we'd
be looking at LinkedIn,
at Facebook, at all of the
obvious social networking
players and say, let's do
the same thing as them.
But guess what?
Strava is probably, possibly
one of the only Silicon Valley
brands that people
tattoo on their ankles
because they are so
passionate about it.
So we need to look at the
likes of Harley-Davidson
for inspiration, not
those other brands.
Or, in terms of
an ad marketplace,
we're more relevant to look
at the local cycling shop
and how they are
curating products
for their passionate riders,
the necessary regular online ad
marketplace.
So thinking about
breaking yourself down
and getting inspiration
from other places.
And then lastly-- apologies
for putting that Disney song
into your heads.
It's going to stay there now--
let it go.
And what I mean by this
is breaking yourself down
by definition means
letting go of things
that are comfortable to you.
And it's not going to
feel good, but what
happens on the
other side is always
profound amounts of growth.
I think about whether that means
relocating to a different city
because you got a
job opportunity.
Whether it means moving
into a different department
that you're uncomfortable with.
Always, you have to let
go of something that
was comfortable to get there.
But always, once
you're through it,
it's incredibly empowering
in terms of how you grow.
And I would say from all
of the people I interviewed
for my book, this was the
one thing that really blew me
away the most, was
that these were
like massively
accomplished people
at the top of their game.
Yet, so willing to be humble
and take a step back and say,
I'm going to start
over in something
because I want to learn
more, which is a hard thing
to do when you're already
at the top of your game.
So it is about letting go.
And that's my three
lessons for the day.
So making failure
your fuel, knowing
what your specialist game is.
And then lastly, break
himself to make yourself,
to really push yourself
to the next level.
And so with that, I think
we have time for questions,
I believe.
Don't be shy.
Hi there.
AUDIENCE: So you started the
talk about how in New Zealand,
there was a big focus on
exercise and outdoor activity.
So do you think that maybe
what didn't go well at Atari
and some of the others were even
just the content of the job?
Like you had to
work at a company
where you had core
values or passions?
SARAH ROBB O'HAGAN:
Definitely, yeah.
I think passions
and understanding.
Because you're 100% right.
I can still remember being in
this office in Santa Monica--
this is at Atari-- with a ton
of the programming guys who
would--
literally, they
had zero interest
in going outside into any
part of the universe other
than working together.
And I was just like,
how is that possible?
It's sunny outside.
We should all be
going for a run.
It just was a total disconnect.
And I don't judge
that group of people.
That's their lifestyle.
But I don't understand it.
I didn't have a
connection to it.
So I think it's important to
not only have a passion for it.
But when you do, you have a
lot more just sheer confidence
to make decisions
and take risks.
So in the case of
video games, you're
faced with, should I
do this or should I
do that in picking which title
we're going to get behind
for the Christmas season?
I don't know. because
I'm not that player.
Yet, when I'm in
suddenly, Nike, it's
like asking me questions
about how an athlete is
going to respond to something.
I'm like, I got this
because I lived it.
I know it.
So I do think it is about
the content, but also
your own just drive and passion
to get behind it for sure.
AUDIENCE: Well, thank you
very much for your talk.
I loved the point about really
knowing what you're great at
and focusing and
doubling down on that.
And I'm wondering if you could
talk a little bit more about,
do you think about that as
like a functional expertise,
an industry expertise,
the type of organization
to be a part of?
Because I think
what's interesting
is you did many different
things at different places.
So kind of, what's
the common thread
between knowing what
you're really good at?
SARAH ROBB O'HAGAN: And
what's the common thread
between airlines, music,
video games, and sports?
Because I think that
is a great question.
And one of the things that
I write about in the book
is that I believe
that the system is
designed to make you fit in.
I think for most of us,
whether it's in high school.
You know how we all
kind of got labeled
as you're either
super-smart, or a jock,
or-- and likewise, you
get your first job.
And I do think your first job--
like recruiters are typically
going to want to keep
you in the same place.
I was in the airlines for six
years, and all I wanted to do
was work for Nike.
Like in my head, I'm a
marketing person in a brand.
It doesn't matter
what category it is.
But the recruiters were like,
you're an airline person.
And I'm like, do I look
like I sniff jet fuel?
Like, no.
I'm not.
Do you know what I mean?
And so I do believe that
you are the only one that
can navigate yourself
out of those verticals
that people will put you into.
And you have to do it.
And then, the
question is, you ask,
is it industry or functional?
I actually think it's a process
of self-discovery to figure out
what it is for you.
It might be that you're just
bang on in the right industry
and that's exactly
where you should be.
Or, as I found
actually, with a lot
of the people I
interviewed, many of them
didn't figure out
where they're place
was to sort of land until
well into their 30s.
And even though
you might go, well,
did that mean the first
10 years was wasted?
No.
Like in every
instance, it was kind
of taking an expertise from here
and connecting it over here.
Great example is one
of my favorite stories
in the book was a woman
who had done her MBA.
She was consulting and
in the music industry.
And so she was doing marketing,
representing Gwen Stefani like
at the top of the game, right?
Yet, deep down inside,
she was a singer.
And she's like, I'm really
miserable because I'm marketing
all these other
people and I'm not
going back to what
I did as a child.
So she goes and basically,
long story short,
studies her singing again
and ends up coming back
and ends up singing
at the Oscars
when "Slumdog Millionaire"
was nominated.
It's a great story.
Which leads her into--
OK, now I'm going to
be a full-time artist.
And who would have thought
all that business experience
enabled her to create--
she's now created her own brand.
So it does come together.
And I think it's
just about having
the willingness to
pursue new experiences,
even if it means it feels
like you're starting over
because you're not.
You're going to be adding
it to what you already had.
Definitely.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much.
Two questions.
One, I'm curious what
your sport was or is
in addition to spinning.
And then second, I
thought the breakdown
of competitive,
social, and convenience
was really interesting.
And from the
perspective of Flywheel,
competitive
definitely makes sense
with the spinning part of it.
How does barre fit into that?
Because if you're going for a
specialization of competition,
that to me doesn't
quite [INAUDIBLE].
SARAH ROBB O'HAGAN: It's
very different, for sure.
At Flywheel, we have
the secondary offering
called FlyBarre, which is
a barre workout, for anyone
who knows what that is.
It doesn't feel
like it's the right
complement because it
feels like it would
be a different type of consumer,
but it is precision training.
And what we find
is that people who
are doing Flywheel, that's
doing a lot of cardio for them.
But they also need
to complement that.
And our barre program is not
the easiest one on the market
by any stretch.
And so I think it really appeals
to that person who's like, OK,
I'm in.
I'm going to go and
really feel it today.
So it does actually end up
connecting because of the type
of programming that it is.
And then to answer your
question, I tried field hockey.
Failed.
Tried tennis.
Skiing.
Failed.
Water skiing.
Sailing.
All of the above.
But now I do a lot of
Flywheel, obviously.
And running.
And I do Tough Mudders.
Anyone in this room
done Tough Mudder?
One of the great stories
in the book, by the way,
is Will, the founder
of Tough Mudder,
because that's a great example
to your question of his parents
are like, can't you
just go be a consultant?
And he's like, no, I want to
electrocute people for fun.
It didn't sound like it was
going to be a huge success.
Now, I believe they have
something like 3 million people
have taken these
things globally.
I mean, it's off-the-chart
success story.
But a great example
of he had taken
all these weird experiences.
He worked in the
Counterterrorism Unit.
He went to Harvard
Business School,
like all these crazy things
to create this sort of unheard
of concept.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So one thing that I really
like about Flywheel,
and I think a lot
of other people do,
is how it's like kind of on the
forefront of workout technology
and how you can learn so
much more about yourself.
So my question for you is
kind of like, what technology
is coming next for Flywheel?
And like, where
are you guys going
to take it in, say, five years?
SARAH ROBB O'HAGAN:
Oh, it's coming.
So yeah, it's a great question.
Because Flywheel actually
pioneered the technology
on the bike.
So for anyone who has been in
the world of fitness for years,
spinning was created in
the '90s, like spinning,
indoor cycling.
But for many, years,
you could be that person
in the back of a
dark room when they
said turn up the
resistance and you're
sort of kind of pretending.
Not really.
And what Flywheel did was
add technology to the bike
so that when you were riding,
the instructor would say,
I want your
resistance to be here
and I want you to
be hitting this
on the RPMs, which is holding
you very, very accountable,
as you know.
And what's neat
about that, I think,
is that people can
then hold themselves
accountable over a long period
of time to how they're doing.
So now, I do believe--
and just with the team that we
are working with at Flywheel,
we all believe that the future
of fitness is accountability.
I think we're going to see
this more and more and more
across every category,
where people--
they want to know the output of
that particular piece of effort
compared to anything else
that they were doing.
It's not a perfect science yet,
because we can't track things
like barre in the same way
that we can a cycling workout.
But I believe that's where
all of our effort needs to go.
I also believe that
the fitness industry--
and as you guys know, we
have the quantified self--
we got a little bit
too carried away
with tracking the data as
opposed to giving insights
of the data.
Going from sort of numbers
to knowledge, if you will.
And I do think that's
also where the future is.
How do we use that data
to prod you, to push you,
to get you to go
to the next level?
So we definitely have
a lot of things coming.
There's a big
announcement, actually,
coming in three weeks.
So watch the space.
But very much, we believe that
technology and accountability
is at the core of where
fitness is going for sure.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So I love your message of
extreme mastery and focus.
I was also interested,
though, when you talked
about challenging yourself.
And if you're a creative person,
try to be more analytical.
So how do you balance the two?
And how do you decide,
when do you just
focus on mastery versus
challenging yourself
to something you're not good at?
SARAH ROBB O'HAGAN: So I'll
give you a personal example.
Because I think
all of us, when we
play to our extreme
strengths, you
go to a different
level of performance.
And for me, innovation,
creativity, all these things,
have always been like,
that I can do easily.
Then, I find myself
president of a $5 billion
business that's needing
to be turned around.
And by the way, when I was 20,
I failed stage 1 accounting.
And so in my head, had my entire
career told myself, I suck.
I suck.
I can't do this.
Avoided it.
You And finally, I was in a job
where you can't hide anymore.
And so I actually,
like eventually
put my hand up to my boss
and I said, this is an issue.
I ended up going down
the street actually
to Harvard Remedial
Finance, which was
awesome for so many reasons.
But here's the thing, I
will never be like a CFO.
But what I did come
back with was actually
a real passion for it.
I've really enjoyed
it and loved it.
And it is just a
complement so that I
have a better view that I can
balance my strengths with.
So that's one
example where I think
you need to make sure you're not
just ignoring the blind spots.
That said, I also know I
will never, in any role,
not surround myself with
a really amazing CFO
because that's not ever going
to be my biggest strength.
So it's about knowing kind
of how to surround yourself
with the opposite skills as
well as kind of just shoring up
your knowledge to make sure
it's not a blind spot is
what I would say.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
SARAH ROBB O'HAGAN: Hi.
AUDIENCE: Thanks
so much for coming.
So a lot of us work at, well,
a very large company or work
with very large companies where
the break yourself to make
yourself is more challenging.
And so when you're working in
one of those larger cultures
that has a lot of inertia
to not change or not break
their own organization,
what advice
do you have for staying
true to your own individual,
and then also impacting
a potential break
in that organization and
leading that yourself?
SARAH ROBB O'HAGAN: Yeah.
One of my favorite
chapters in the book
actually is what I
call "Change the Game."
And it's my personal
experience of actually
being at Gatorade, which PepsiCo
you may work with, some of you,
is a giant company
within which Gatorade
was one $5 billion piece.
And it required--
I mean, this was a business
that after the recession
was a $5 billion top line
that lost $500 million
off the top line in 1 year.
I mean, it was huge, right?
And so small, incremental change
clearly wasn't going to do it.
Yet, to move everyone
along-- like everything
that we were needing to
do to fix the business
went totally counter to what had
worked for a really long time.
And so you sort of--
I remember along the
way having-- and there's
a lot of dramatic moments in
the story where we thought
we were heading
the right direction
and the business
didn't start turning.
And everyone's questioning,
have I totally screwed
up the business?
All of the above.
But I do believe,
like in that case,
I had two things going for me.
One was that by now, I have
developed this real specialty
of understanding athletes,
innovation in that space,
and I knew it better than anyone
in terms of the broader peer
group because it was
where I'd grown up.
And secondly, I'd been
fired twice in my 20s.
So every step of
the way, I remember
saying to myself, to
the point of inertia,
if I play on the defense,
we're not going to win.
And I am going to get fired.
If I play on the
offense, there's
a good chance we'll win.
And there's also a decent
chance I'll get fired,
but that's OK because
I've been there before.
And I'd rather go
down trying to do
what I did know how to do best.
And I do believe for
all of us, like we
get into these situations,
particularly in big companies.
And particularly, in
times like the recession,
where the fear kicks in.
And everyone's
like, but the boss
said they wanted blah, blah.
And this is what
I've been told to do.
But the boss doesn't
want you to please them.
They want you to drive results.
And I think as long as you can
frame what you're doing around,
I know this doesn't
feel right, but here's
the line from a to b.
And stay with it.
And like, go with all
your specialty skills.
That's the other thing
I really believe in.
You will have so
much more conviction
if you come from a place that's
your own personal expertise.
And you kind of have no choice
but to go against the inertia.
Because in the end, what
happens if you don't?
So I love that
question, by the way.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: One more question
if no one else is in line.
When it comes to the space that
you're in, sort of fitness,
sports in general,
is there a trend
that you sort of see coming up
behind you that you're like,
huh.
That's sort of interesting.
I wonder where that goes?
Whether it's in the breakdown
of the three different kind
of spaces, or in your
kind of fitness, or sort
of what are you seeing out
of the corner of your eye?
SARAH ROBB O'HAGAN:
It's a great question.
I definitely believe that
the boutique specializing
phenomenon is at the very
beginning of where it's going.
Boutique fitness has grown
400% in the last 4 years
and big box gyms
have stayed flat.
And what's interesting
is that people are coming
into the boutique category--
a little bit of it is coming
from big, full-service gyms.
A lot of it is people coming in
to fitness for the first time.
It's creating a lot of
energy in the category.
I mean, health and wellness
is in a great place.
But I believe with
boutique, we're
still at the very beginning.
Because nobody's really blown
up and scaled yet the way if you
go back to retail in the '90s,
like some of those boutique
brands really took
it to the next level.
And I believe what I'm
seeing, at least, is
there's a lot of people
coming into the fitness space
right now.
Whether it's sophisticated
investors, leaders, whatever.
I believe it's all going
to start going upwards
and scaling in a big way.
I also think that
technology is going
to be a huge driver in
omni-channel experiences.
I think that's going to be--
so that you can be a part
of the Flywheel community,
and you can participate
in it wherever
you may be around the world.
I think that's a big piece
of where we're going.
That said, I do think that the
in-person experience is not
going away.
And what I mean by that is, if
you look across retail right
now, definitely
retail in general
is suffering because everything
is moving to e-commerce.
But look at what's booming.
It's things like theme
parks, restaurants, fitness.
Because I believe humans are
craving time with other humans.
And that's what those kind
of businesses are bringing,
is experiences together.
So I think that's
not going to go away.
In fact, I think there's a lot
more opportunity right there.
AUDIENCE: Who were your
favorite two subjects that you
interviewed for the book?
And for any kind of quirky,
different reason than people
might imagine.
SARAH ROBB O'HAGAN:
You're so funny.
I can't.
It's like picking
one of my children.
I'll pick two
interesting subjects.
Firstly, I will start
by saying there's
an amazing Googler in
the book, Dan Keyserling,
if anyone knows.
He now works in Jigsaw.
So he's a fan favorite.
You can find him.
But I would say probably
the unexpected ones
that really blew
me away were Mister
Cartoon, the tattoo artist,
was just phenomenal in terms
of where he came from,
where he got to, how he just
had this incredible ability
to get uncomfortable and keep
learning.
And some of his one-liners
were just awesome.
I really, really loved him.
And then, there's
a personal story.
Actually, a connection to me.
My sister-in-law-- and
it's an incredible story
of overcoming
profound mental health
issues to become really quite
successful on the global stage.
And so different to
anything else in the book,
but so incredibly inspiring.
But they're all amazing.
They were great stories.
Definitely.
AUDIENCE: How do you think
about the competition?
Let's use SoulCycle.
Obviously, according
to you categories,
they're in maybe
a different one.
But how much do you as the
CEO pay attention to them
without getting too
paranoid or too distracted,
but still make
sure that you know
what you're up against if
they're your top competitor?
SARAH ROBB O'HAGAN: Yeah.
Well, first of all,
I'm going to say
something that will
probably sound surprising,
but I love SoulCycle.
And I believe that when they do
well, the category does well.
We all do well.
Same with Peloton.
I actually believe all of us
are bringing tons of energy
and all the boats are rising.
And what's really
interesting is they
are very different
consumers, people coming
for very different reasons.
So I don't spend a
lot of time thinking
about them because I do
spend a lot of time thinking
about our core
consumer who's looking
for something quite different.
And I would say I personally
learned a lot from working
at a company like Virgin
or Nike where they never
thought about the competition
and only play their own game
compared to the soda wars.
You know, Coke and
Pepsi, Powerade/Gatorade,
where it's a completely
different mindset.
And that can drag you
into different places
that aren't necessarily
right for your consumers.
So I think I came away with
that going stay focused.
Definitely.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
so much for coming.
I'm a Flywheel devotee, so I'm
so excited to see you here.
And for those who
haven't tried it,
we have a great
Googler discount.
SARAH ROBB O'HAGAN: Oh, yes.
AUDIENCE: Try it out.
SARAH ROBB O'HAGAN:
We definitely do.
AUDIENCE: In the vein of--
I know you had mentioned
that boutique fitness is
sort of just starting and
it's going to explode.
What do you foresee as one of
the biggest challenges facing
Flywheel in the coming years?
SARAH ROBB O'HAGAN: I would
say staying focused, actually.
Because I do think
that there is a ton
of excitement around the
fitness category in general.
I also think daily, there is
new technology and innovation
that people knocking down our
door, wanting to suggest we
do this, that, and the other.
And I personally have found--
because I had not grown up in
a technology company like you
all, as a CEO, it's hard
to sort the real ideas
from the many
things that are just
going to fall by the wayside
and not get distracted
by the wrong ones.
So I actually think the
opportunity is so ripe for us,
but we have to--
we've got to place the right
bets, and focus on them,
and not get spread
too thin, I would say.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
With your focus and
leadership on technology
and accountability
in the fitness space,
are you all thinking about
integrating fitness data
with larger health care data?
And how is that materializing?
SARAH ROBB O'HAGAN: Yes.
We are at the very
beginning of being
able to think about
it because we're still
a very young company.
But for sure, I think that's
what we all need to do.
That's what our
consumers want us to do,
is help them get a
more holistic picture.
So absolutely.
Definitely.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
You mentioned a lot about like
failing early and failing fast.
I was wondering if you could
talk a little bit about also
like during the times
when you have failed,
like how did you go about
picking yourself back up?
SARAH ROBB O'HAGAN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: What are the
different support networks
you had to allow
that introspection
and get yourself to be propelled
up for that post-growth?
SARAH ROBB O'HAGAN: Yeah.
So let's talk about failing fast
for a second and failing hard.
Maybe I'll use that term.
Because fail fast is a big
idea that thankfully, you guys
have brought to the
world in general
in terms of as we
are in business
and thinking about innovation,
trying, experimenting,
iterating, rolling, and moving.
And we all have to be
better at doing that.
That is different to failure
that really deeply impacts
you, and teaches you, and
actually takes you personally
to another level.
And that is one of the reasons
I went to great lengths
to just put it all out there.
And by the way, I'm
not the only one.
Like some of the other
stories in my book,
I said to everyone when
I interviewed them,
I don't want the great
surface amazingness.
Tell me how it felt. And
like Condoleezza Rice, making
the decision, extraordinarily
tough decision,
to give up on her dream of being
a concert pianist and take a--
tell me what that feels like.
But what I would say is you
have to-- like I actually
break down in the book
the real process of how
you should go through it.
Because everyone says to me,
how do you go into an interview
after you've just
been fired twice,
which is a good question.
But you have to, I believe,
really feel it and process it.
And if you've ever
had a failure--
I know in my case, I
spent the first, at least
month telling everyone around
me that it was their fault.
You know, it must have
been the sucky industry,
the leadership, whatever.
And everyone you
tell that to, you
can sort of see in their
eyes that they don't really
believe you.
And that's because you
don't really believe you.
And then you have to just
sit there and go, OK.
This hurts.
I'm going to own it.
But the minute you actually
take ownership for it
and man up and
say it to someone.
Like in a job
interview saying, I
got fired because I did this,
which means I will never
make that mistake again, it's so
empowering because you own it.
You're in control
of it from then on.
So I do think we all tend
to-- it's human nature
to want to cover up
fails because you
kind of think it's a bad thing.
But when you do, it's like
this scary thing that's always
chasing you through life.
And maybe it's going to
catch up and someone's going
to find out about it one day.
It's better just
to feel it, own it.
And then, by the way,
you do get great growth.
And that's what you
did it for, right?
I always tell people,
don't fail if you're not
going to get the output on
the other side, for sure.
All right.
I think my little counter
clock is about to run out.
So thank you very much.
It's been really fun.
Great questions.
Thanks a lot.
[APPLAUSE]